[Applause]
good morning
dear uh colleagues just before we
welcome the Prime Minister I wanted to
take a moment to express the horror of
the European Parliament at the terror
attack in Brussels yesterday so at noon
today uh I will make a short uh
statement on this with a round of
speakers and I invite you all to be in
the chamber with us
dear colleagues today we have Nicole
pashinyan Prime Minister of Armenia with
us prime minister Dear Nicole Welcome to
the European
Parliament we are in the context of the
events of 19th September in nagoro kabak
in our last plenary we voted on a
resolution that deplored the attack on
nagoro kabak and called for the respect
of Armenians rights and security and our
Focus now must be on honest and fair
talks uh to resume prime minister since
then your country your people have
welcomed housed and fed over 100,000
refugees it is a testament to your
country's commitment Europe will
continue to support armenia's efforts in
dealing with the influx of people from
nagoro kabak many member states have
also donated much needed shelter
equipment
food and medical supplies to the EU
civil protection mechanism prime
minister let me also assure you of our
support to your country's Democratic
reforms the strengthening of our
bilateral relations and stronger
cooperation with the European Union
active participation of the
International Community as well as
International assurances for Armenians
who continue to live in nagorno kabak
can help achieve peace and
Reconciliation we remain committed to
all efforts directed towards the
normalization of relations between
Armenia and aeran based on Mutual
recognition of sovereignty inviability
of borders and territorial Integrity
dear prime minister de Nicole let me
assure you that Armenia remains a vital
partner for us in the eu's Eastern
neighborhood the EU stands ready to f
support the democratically elected
authorities of Armenia the resilience
security and continuation of democratic
reforms in the country prime minister
the floor is
[Applause]
yours
thank you very much I will speak
our esteemed president of the European
Parliament dear members of the
parliament dear
guests it's a great honor for me to
speak from this high rostrom and I'm
grateful for this
opportunity our
government and the people of the
Republic of Armenia and know the
European Parliament as an entity which
at all times of challenges faced by the
Republic of Armenia and the Armenians of
nagoro kabak has been vocal and has been
vocal in the language of the
truth I thank all of you for this among
other things because there's power in
the truth and that power you generate at
each time has benefited us too the
common narrative these days is that
Democratic Armenia is experiencing dire
challenges and it is the
truth another truth is that Armenia
democracy is experiencing dire
challenges the greatest truth
nonetheless is that democracy in Armenia
is experiencing dire challenges
and not just armenia's
democracy but democracy
overall because various events unfolding
in Armenia and around the world are
raising the following question is
democracy capable of providing peace
security
solidarity prosperity and
happiness but I have not come here to
ask questions I have come here to answer
and my answer is yes
unequivocally many say that Armenia
today is suffering because of
democracy but I must underline my
belief with the largely inevitable
challenges faced by Armenia in recent
years the Republic of Armenia would have
have simply become paralyzed lost her
independence and sovereignty had it not
been
Democratic this is evidenced by the
events of 2020 and
after signing the trilateral ceasefire
statement at the end of the 44-day war
when armenia's State institutions were
targeted by attacks of extremist groups
when the public was divided and
inflamed democratically formed
institutions stood strong in their
positions of
Defending
statehood whilst not breaching any
principles of
democracy the freedom of expression and
the freedom of assembly were not
restricted in Armenia in that difficult
situation there were no cases of
disproportionate use of force and the
rule of law was not undermined
and even though we continue to enjoy
majority in the
parliament in order to overcome the
social psychological crisis that was
caused by the aftermath of the war the
ruling power the Civil contract
party decided to call a snap
parliamentary election for that purpose
I stepped down from my position of the
Prime Minister and then in accordance
with the pro legal procedure the
Parliament and the government were
dissolved two days after the Thea entry
into force of the dissolution of the
parliament on 12th May
2021 the azerbaijani troops violated the
border with Armenia at a border stretch
of about 100 kilomet they invaded
armenia's Sovereign territory at depths
of up to 4
kilm in this
situation the collective security
security Treaty Organization considered
to be armenia's security system and
countries that had security obligations
bilaterally towards Armenia did nothing
to help us they left us all
alone the purpose of this provocation
ahead of the upcoming parliamentary
election was to cause that election to
fail and to paralyze Armenian statehood
or as as as a minimum to install a
puppet
government but in this environment
armenia's people were able to stand
strong for defending armenia's
Independence sovereignty and
democracy and we held a parliamentary
election that was internationally
recognized as free Democratic
transparent and
competitive for the first time in the
history of the Republic of Armenia
elections became a means for overcoming
a domestic crisis and not VI Versa this
was the difference the main difference
between the Armenia that existed before
the
2018 nonviolent Velvet Revolution of the
people and the one that came after the
revolution before the Revolution
elections would normally trigger
internal
crises due to the lack of public trust
in the outcome After the Revolution
elections have helped to prevent or
overcome crisis because citizens now
have not only a theoretical but also a
practical opportunity to carry out
decisions and to have these decisions
respected after the 2018 nonviolent
Velvet Revolution of the people no
election in Armenia at any level or any
election results have not been
rigged 6 years ago people would have
laughed at references to their right to
form a government through elections and
now they would not understand what
falsification or rigging of election
results could mean this is what has
changed in Armenia in the last five
years but democracy in Armenia has
continued to suffer from heavy blows
which operate on an almost exactly
repeatable formula external aggression
followed by the inactivity of armenia's
security allies followed by attempts to
capitalize on the war or the
humanitarian situation or the external
security threats for overthrowing
armenia's democracy and sovereignty
or attempts which are manifested in the
form of incitement of domestic
instability via hybrid Technologies
steered by external
actors since 2020 we've had several of
these situations the largest of which
was azer Ban's wholesale attack on
Armenia on 13 December
which resulted in the occupation of
armenia's sovereign
territories the latest and most tragic
of such events unfolded quite
recently when
aeran in furtherance of its yearslong
policy of ethnic cleansing Unleashed a
wholesale attack on nagoro
kabak when 100,000 Armenians were
fleeing from nagoro kabak to the
Republic of
Armenia our security allies were not
only not helping us but were publicly
appealing for a change of power and
overthrowing of the democratic
government in
Armenia but the people of the Republic
of Armenia came together for our own
independence sovereignty and
democracy and yet another plot conspired
against our state
failed the government and the people of
the Republic of Armenia came together
for hosting and providing shelter to
over 100,000 Armenians that were
victimized by the ethnic cleansing in
nagoro
kabak we have done this
honorably to the extent that our
International Partners
confess that they have never seen a
situation in which a country would
receive 100,000 refugees and would be
able to accommodate all of them without
setting up refugee camps or tent
towns we've been able to do
this thanks to armenia's people and
[Applause]
democracy we were able to do
this thanks to armenia's people and
democracy the people because at times
they would not even wait for the
government to do
anything they would provide essential
supplies to the forcibly
displaced and they would even provide
temporary
shelter many of them received these
people in their
homes thanks to democracy because after
the 2018
Revolution all obstacles to doing
business freely and all artificial
monopolies have been eliminated in
Armenia government transparency and
accountability have
improved there's there has been an
uncompromising principled and
institutional effort against corruption
the rule of law has been achieved and
with all of this in spite of the
tragedies and the threats Armenia
continues to enjoy strong economic
growth since
2018 my country's fiscal revenues have
grown by about
70% with decisions that have already
been taken we will be allocating around
$100
million in support to those displaced
from nagoro kabak and we do need
international support including in the
form of budget
support needless to say we have created
a mechanism for supporting the forcibly
displaced under this mechanism the
resources allocated to them are
transferred in non-cash form thus the
distribution of resources is transparent
verifiable and traceable and the system
will continue to operate in this
manner and we're grateful to our
International part Partners to the EU
and to the member
states for having already made
allocations or having continued to make
allocations for coping with the
humanitarian crisis caused by the forced
displacement of the Armenians from
nagoro
kabak esteemed president of the European
Parliament honorable members of the
parliament dear guests it is unfortunate
extremely unfortunate that in spite of
hundreds of
reports the orders of the international
court of justice resolutions of the
European Parliament resolutions of the
Parliamentary assembly of the Council of
Europe and resolutions of national
parliaments as well as the appeals of
the executive governments we the
International Community have been unable
to prevent the ethnic cleansing of
Armenians from nagoro kabak The Armenian
government and the European Parliament
have many times alerted to the threat of
ethnic cleansing in nagoro kabak the
Armenian
government repeatedly invited the UN the
osc and the EU to
send a fact-f finding mission to
the blockaded Lain Corridor or to nagoro
kabak however none of of them adopted
such decisions we initiated three un
Security Council discussions on this
topic but the discussions produced no
practical results and now nagoro kabak
has been cleansed of
Armenians with the inactivity of the
peacekeeping mission of the Russian
Federation over 100,000
Armenians left their homes in their
native land of nagoro kabak in a matter
matter of one week another 20,000 H had
been forced out of nagoro kabak
immediately after the 44 day war in
2020 many others had been unable to
return to nagoro kabak because of the
illegal blockade of the loding corridor
that had started in December
2022 and now some are pretending not to
understand why the Armenians of nagoro
kabak left their homes on M
posing such a question is cynicism per
se because the answer is glaringly
obvious aeran had clearly and
unequivocally demonstrated its decision
to render life for Armenians in nagoro
kabak impossible from December
2022 during the illegal blockade of the
Lain Corridor the Armenians of nagoro
kabak were deprived of of natural gas
electricity fuel
food baby formula
medication hygiene supplies as well as
other essential
supplies civilians performing
agriculture Works were targeted by azer
Ban's armed
forces from December
we made dozens of alerts about AER Ban's
plan to push people into hunger to
increase the military propaganda and
psychological pressure and then to open
the Lin Corridor forcing thus all
Armenians to
leave we described this scenario in
January February March April May June
July August of 20123 we described it
loudly and publicly and I do not
understand the surprised faces of
certain International
officials about the cleansing of nagorna
kabak of Armenians in September yet I
would like to thank the European
Parliament for calling what happened in
nagoro kabak by its
name this is important for the future
protection of the rights of people
deprived of their
Homeland esteemed president
honorable members of the parliament dear
attendees in spite of all the wars and
difficulties and crisis I have come to
the European Parliament with the
following key
message our region the South Caucasus is
in need of
Peace in need of a condition where all
the countries of the region live with
open bord
ERS Tied by active economic political
and cultural
bonds with experience and tradition of
resolving all differences by diplomatic
means and by
dialogue I want to highlight our vision
of peace is not in any way opposed to
the interests of our region because our
country can be PE peaceful if the region
is in
peace and supporting the
construction of peace is my core
political
undertaking assuming such an undertaking
is not easy given the long-standing
conflict with
aeran and the fact that there have been
numerous casualties missing persons
prisoners suffering and despair but is
peace possible and if if yes
how in early
October ahead of the third European
political Community Summit in
Granada we
had a major opportunity to achieve a
breakthrough in the peace process but
unfortunately the president of aeran
refused to attend the summit and to
adopt a joint statement with the EU
council president the president of
France the chancellor of Germany and
myself a statement that would contain
the principles of achieving peace and
normalizing relations between Armenia
and
aeran however those principles and
content were not elaborated in
Granada as a result of the quadrilateral
meeting in Prague on October 6 2022 they
were elaborated
back then and that meeting in Prague was
attended by the French President the EU
council president the president of aeran
and myself these principles were fleshed
out in 2023 during meetings between the
EU council president the president of
aeran and myself in Brussels and there
have been public statements about these
principles the first one the first
principle is contained in the Granada
quadrilateral statement in the following
way
quote they meaning the French President
the EU council president the German
Chancellor and
myself remain committed to all efforts
directed towards the normalization of
relations between Armenia and
aeran based on Mutual recognition of
sovereignty inviability of borders and
territorial Integrity of Armenia
29,800 sare kilm and of aeran 86,00
square
kilm as mentioned in president
Michelle's statements of 14 May and 15
July
2023 they called for the strict
adherence to the principle of non-use of
force and threat of use of force end of
quote
as a result of the trilateral meeting
held in Brussels on 14 may this
year between the EU council president
the president of aeran and
myself EU council president Char
Michelle published a statement that
reads as follows quote the leaders
meaning the president of aeran and
myself confirmed their unequivocal
commitment to the 1991 almati techler
ation and the respective territorial
Integrity of Armenia
29,800 kilm and aeran
86,00 square
kilomet end of
quote as a result of the July 15 meeting
in Brussel between the EU council
president the president of aeran and
myself another statement was public
published by council president
Michelle which reads as follows quote
The Armenian and aani leaders once again
fully reconfirmed their respect for the
other Count's territorial integrity and
sovereignty based on the understanding
that armenia's territory covers
29,800 squ kilm and azer Jan's territory
86,000 600 square kilm end of
quote ladies and
gentlemen what you need to know in
addition about this is the following
after these understandings I made
several public statements reconfirming
that the Republic of Armenia
recognizes azerbaijan's
86,00 square kilometer territorial
Integrity but the aeran president has
not
reciprocated he recently stated that he
recognizes armenia's territorial
Integrity but he did not specify the
29,800 which has caused some analysts to
concern that he is intentionally leaving
ambiguities for making territorial
claims on
Armenia the understanding to recognize
territorial Integrity with specific
numbers was achieved for that very
purpose so
that neither Armenia nor aeran would
afford any ambiguity in recognizing each
other's territorial Integrity by saying
for instance that a part of the of of
the country's territory does not really
belong to that
country the next principle of
normalizing relations between Armenia
and aeran is contained in the Granada
statement in the following manner
quote they stressed the urgent need to
work towards border
delimitation based on the most recent
USSR general staff maps that have been
provided to the
sides which should also be a basis for
distancing of
forces and for finalizing the peace
treaty and addressing all humanitarian
issues end of
quote
as a result of the July 15 meeting held
in Brussels with the EU council
president the president of azerbajan and
myself council president charl Michelle
made the following statement
quote both leaders reconfirmed their
unequivocal commitment to the 1991
almati declaration as a political
framework for the delimitation end of
quote
as a result of the 2022 October
6 quadrilateral meeting in Prague the
same principle was defined as follows
quote Armenia and aeran confirmed their
commitment to the Charter of the UN and
to the 1991 almati declaration through
which both recognize each other's
territorial integrity and
sovereignty they confirmed it would be a
basis for the work of the Border
delimitation
commissions end of
quote what you need to know additionally
about this principle is the following
the almati Declaration was signed by the
12 republics of the Soviet Union on
December 21
1991 in this context
there were two important Clauses in that
declaration firstly the Soviet Union
shall cease to exist and secondly the
republics shall recognize each other's
territorial integrity and
sovereignty the inviolability of the
existing administrative borders and
therefore the administrative borders
between the P ex Soviet republics would
turn into state
borders aeran has claimed that there is
no border between Armenia and aeran but
this contradicts the almati Declaration
and the aforementioned
understandings aeran also maintains
ambiguity
in accepting the most recent Soviet
Union Maps as a basis for
delimitation some
experts have assumed based on this that
as a Zan is creating a foundation for
territorial claims and a new military
aggression against
Armenia ladies and
gentlemen the next principle for
normalizing relations between Armenia
and aeran and for peace is contained in
the Granada
statement as follows quote they called
for the opening of regional connectivity
links based on full respect of the
country's sovereign
and
jurisdiction as well as on the
principles of equality and reciprocity
end of
quote in his statement on July 15 after
the meeting held in Brussels between the
EU council president the president of
aeran and myself council president Char
Michelle stated the following quote
we meaning EU council president the
president of azerbajan and myself
discussed modalities of future transport
Arrangements which will respect the
principles of sovereignty jurisdiction
and reciprocity end of
quote what you should know about this
principle in addition is the following
aeran has continued to claim that
Armenia must provide find a corridor to
aeran Via armenia's own territory in
common International talk we understand
a corridor as a simple Interstate road
but in our region there's a
specificity in the 2020 November 9
trilateral statement the word Corridor
is used only in reference to the Lain
Corridor which was supposed to ensure a
link between nagoro kabak and
Armenia the specificity is that under
the 2020 November 9 statement Lain
Corridor would not just be a road it
would be a 5 kilomet wide territorial
layer that would lie outside of Aer
Ban's control and would be under the
control of the peacekeepers so in this
context the word
Corridor has that connotation of an extr
territorial layer
Armenia has never under any
circumstances agreed to or promised to
accept any restriction of its
sovereignty or jurisdiction Armenia has
not made such a promise so what does the
aforementioned principle mean it simply
means that Armenia and aeran agreed on
the basis of their sovereignty and
jurisdiction and without any reference
to
corridors to open each other's roads for
the other to open their roads for each
other at the checkpoints of these roads
there would be border control and other
control services under the jurisdiction
of the respective countries and based on
their sovereignty and legislation this
would be
done according to the principle of
reciprocity and equality we are ready
for such Solutions as soon as possible
we are ready to restore the me Railway
linking via the south of Armenia not
just Armenia and aeran but also
armenia's Southern regions with the
Northwestern regions azer Ban's
Southwestern regions with the autonomous
Republic of
nichan Armenia subsequently with turkey
azerbajan with turkey Georgia aeran and
Armenia with the Islamic Republic of
Iran the East with the west from the
Caspian to the
Mediterranean the North to the south
from the Gulf to the Black
Sea in Armenia we call this project The
Armenian
Crossroads but I
think the time has come for further
regionalizing and rebranding this
project and here in this important house
the time has come come for calling it
The Crossroads of Peace a name that
would be just as important and
acceptable for us along the same logic
we are ready for the roads to be opened
the Republic of
Armenia is committed to securing the
movement of goods Vehicles people
pipelines and electricity lines because
in a Crossroads of Peace implies also
the passage of pipelines and electricity
lines these Solutions are very important
for the Republic of Armenia as well
because for 30 years now our country has
been in a blocade by azerbajan and
turkey as you can see there's no basis
for accusing Armenia of obstructing the
opening of regional transport
Communications some analysis indicate
that official Baku
is Miss representing the international
narrative in order to incite a new war
in the region or for occupying further
territories of Armenia or keeping
Armenia in blockade this cannot be
allowed as you saw all of the
aforementioned principles were fleshed
out and agreed upon with the
participation of the EU council
president and the president of azerbajan
we are ready to implement these
understandings as far as transport
Communications are
concerned in accordance with the
aforementioned principle including the
principle of reciprocity we are ready to
simplify the procedures we're ready to
ensure the safe passage of Aer Banis and
AER bani Goods by our
territory hoping for reciprocity we're
ready for the mirrored withdrawal of the
troops
from the 1991 border line which would
mean that azerbajan would not have ter
armed forces in the territory of AR of
Armenia and vice versa we're also ready
on the basis of reciprocity to address
the question of the so-called
enclaves as declared in my interview
with armenia's public television on
October 10 and finally we're ready by
the end of this year to sign an
agreement on peace and normalization of
relations with aeran clearly the fact
that aeran refused to take part in the
Granada meeting which had actually been
agreed upon in Brussels on July 15 and
that agreement too was contained in uh
president Michel's
statement made after the meeting now
that failure to come to the meeting did
not make the process any easier
but in the course of this year as the
president of the parliament has said
we've agreed that we will have a meeting
in
Brussels during this month and if the
affir mention principles are officially
reconfirmed then the signing of a peace
and normalization agreement between
Armenia and aeran will become highly
realistic by the end of this year
we are also ready to have an all for all
exchange of prisoners of War detainees
and arrested persons who ready to
closely cooperate for determining the
fate of the missing persons at the
moment 1,6 citizens of Armenia are
considered to be missing We Stand ready
to cooperate for Dem mining I wish to
emphasize that back in
2021 Armenia received from nagoro kabak
and passed to aeran the all of the maps
of Mine Fields that were available to
The Armenian site we did so without
preconditions as an expression of
Goodwill but unfortunately aeran did not
perceive it as a step aimed at peace but
rather as a trigger for escalating its
aggressive rhetoric against
Armenia in spite of this
we must resolutely move towards
peace doing so requires political
will I and the government and the
Parliamentary majority of Armenia have
this political will on the other hand
the International Community and the
European Union and countries of our
region need to support us to the best of
their ability to
use this opportunity to make it
realistic for us Armenia and aeran this
is where I
seek your continued support at and
attention especially for the realization
of the principles that I
discussed as I said already these
principles were agreed upon with the
participation of council president charl
Michelle and the president of azerbajan
esteemed president honorable members of
the parliament dear attendees turning to
the EU Armenia
relationship in recent
years the EU has been a key partner
supporting the fundamental reforms of
the Armenian
government the Armenia EU comprehensive
and enhanced partnership agreement is
crucial it is one of the pillars of our
reform agenda which is now in the phase
of active implementation from February
Armenia has had a long-term civilian
mission of the European Union which
monitors the security situation
alongside armenia's state border with
azerbajan
this is an important milestone for the
first time the European
Union has become engaged in armenia's
security agenda the foundation for this
was laid during the qu trilateral
meeting in Prague on October 6
2022 as for reforms to strengthen
democracy we receive EU support in our
police reform this month in a matter of
just a few days two weeks in fact we
will
finalize the formation of a an all new
Patrol police in Armenia we expect to
continue cooperating for the reforms of
the police the rescue service the
Judiciary we having an independent
Judiciary education and public
administration our agenda with the EU is
indeed very
extensive it's important to reinvigorate
the projects implemented under the
economic and investment plan of the
EU important objectives
include sustainable economic development
modernization of
infrastructure digitalization and
technological
development and strengthening the
resilience of armenia's Southern regions
the latter is important not only for the
country's development but also for
building durable peace in the region
projects worth more than 400 million
EUR have already launched under this
program about € 270 million EUR are
for
facilitating access to finance about 34
million EUR are for technological
development another 43 million EUR are
for strengthening the resilience of the
sunik region and about 62 million EUR
for the green development of the city of
yvan and this is not
all on October 5th in Granada two very
important documents for the EU Armenia
relationship were
adopted one is the queral statement
between President Michelle President Ma
Chancellor Schultz and myself and the
the other one is the bilateral statement
between President fer lion and myself
both statements Express support
to strengthening the EU Armenia
relationship on all levels in view of
the needs of the Republic of Armenia we
have undertaken to further strengthen
the EU Armenia relationship in the long
run the European Union and Armenia are
committed to strengthening economic IC
ties by unleashing the full potential of
the Armenia EU comprehensive and
enhanced partnership agreement based on
all of this ladies and gentlemen I can
announce clearly and with confidence
Armenia is
ready to be closer to the European
Union as far as the European Union would
consider possible
our joint statements with President F
lion reads in these difficult
times the EU and Armenia stand shoulder
toh shoulder let us continue to stand
shoulder to
shoulder with a commitment to make these
times better as I
said I'm convinced that democracy can
provide peace security
solidarity prosperity and happiness let
us prove this
together Long Live democracy thank
you
[Applause]
so dear colleagues thank you very much
to the Prime Minister of
Armenia uh
yesterday evening
uh terrorist attack happened in the
heart of Brussels resulting in the
murder of two Swedish Nationals and on
behalf of the European Parliament I
express my deepest condolences to the
victims
families Terror and extremism cannot
infiltrate our societies we have the
right